a leaked report by Israel's Intelligence
Service Mossad suggest that the
country's Prime Minister and his own
spies are at odds over Iran's nuclear
capabilities Benjamin Netanyahu said in
2012 and that the Iranians were a year
away from being able to make a nuclear
bomb but the Mossad document
contradicted the assertion middle east
analyst mage ever done far told us that
this apparent discrepancy is nothing new
both believed that Iran it wants to have
the option of making a nuclear weapon
but Netanyahu seems to believe that Iran
is hell-bent on making a nuclear weapon
however according to these reports the
Israeli military establishment has
stated that the Supreme Leader of Iran
has not yet made a decision to assemble
a weapon that this decision has not been
made and this is just one of the many
differences which have surfaced over the
year in terms of the differences
differences in assessment regarding
Iran's nuclear program between the Prime
Minister of Israel under and the
intelligence services another mark and
difference seems to be that according to
the two reports the current head of the
Mossad mr. Pardo and the previous head
of the Mossad mr. Madigan do not believe
that an Iran would actually use a
nuclear weapon against the State of
Israel if it gets one but Netanyahu
seems to completely differ with that
point of view Natalia was right by
saying that Iran is continuing to enrich
uranium at twenty percent and that if
this stockpile of 20-percent enriched
uranium increases it will give you round
the option to make a nuclear weapon but
it seems that the way he made it look
with that diagram it's as if you know
Iran's making a dynamite and all that's
needed is just enrich uranium and an
efuse them and boom there's a bond which
is actually not correct to make a
nuclear weapon more processes are needed
it seems that it
yahoo has undertaken a strategy upon
which by over emphasizing the possible
dangers of nuclear Iran he is trying to
keep the issue on the top of the agenda
of the international community it's
actually quite worrying because Israel
was the first country in the
international community to alert the
international community that Iran had
ambitions to get his hands on a nuclear
weapon and Israel was absolutely correct
in 1990 according to the Washington Post
the Iranians turn to the Pakistanis in
fact the Iranian defense minister went
to Pakistan in order to buy a ready-made
nuclear weapon so Israel was right from
the beginning that Iran has had
intentions but Netanyahu is overdoing it
now by over emphasizing this fact yes
Israel has every right to be concerned
about Iran's nuclear program but no mr.
Netanyahu should not be playing
political games and sometimes
exaggerating this threat because it
hurts what is a very credible possible
threat to the State of Israel